The affiliate industry has a dirty secret.
They want you to sell hype because hype burns fast
and generates quick fees.
But look at your dashboard.
Low conversions?
High churn?
That's because you're leading your audience to 'Hell Island'—a place
where they lose money and never trust you again.
The hidden enemy isn't your traffic; it's the
broken products you're promoting.
Now, imagine a different world.
'Heaven Island.' A place where you offer a shield, not a gamble.
Trap Defence BTC is a Blue Ocean.
We are the only academy that tells users to wait.
This radical honesty creates 50 percent higher conversion rates
because it builds instant, unbreakable trust.
When your audience stays alive, your recurring commissions grow.
Stop burning your reputation for pennies.
Join the elite circle of partners who provide real value.
With our $1,650 average monthly revenue model, your success is as
protected as our users' capital.
Escape the hell of low conversions.
Join us on Heaven Island today.